dès l'arrivée sur les zones de capture
l'équipe ouvre les cages pièges
il s'empare des marcassins un par un
tous vont aller très vite pour ne pas
stresser l'animal il essaie que ces
mesures aient et avant de le relâcher
lui seront posées des boucles
auriculaires d'identité et une puce
électronique
enfin des prélèvements seront effectués
ces numéros du transpondeur qu'on a mis
sur le marcassin donc on les colle les
deux étiquettes sur les deux tubes on va
mettre la date et après on va le boucler
pour l'identifier visuel tout con comme
ça au labour ils ont directement les
numéros du sanglier de transpondeur en
fait il peut attraper des connectiques
des boutons et donc c'est ce qu'on
regarde en observant en observant la
peau de l'animal toute la faune sauvage
que celle des ti coune et des poussées
c'est courant par contre il peut l'être
sauf transmettre de malanje c'est ce
qu'on essaie de voir plus
particulièrement les marcassins
identifie seront recapturer dans
quelques mois
leur étude permettra le suivi de leur
croissance mais également de recueillir
des informations sanitaires car le
sanglier connaît comme toute espèce de
la faune sauvage des maladies
parasitaires ça permet encore une fois
de de savoir comment la population se
porte et comment l'animal et la
population gère ces problèmes là
en tenant compte bien des ressources
alimentaires de l'environnement dans
lequel on se situe voilà comment tout ça
interagit c'est ce qui nous intéresse et
ce sont ces résultats qui vont permettre
de comprendre le fonctionnement de la
population de 100 billets du parc de
chambord et d'éclairer sa gestion ils
seront également comparés à ceux obtenus
ailleurs